okay so here we are my name is arya this
is eating your feed the show where
people like me are challenged to
recreate viral dishes and recipes from
the internet adam has brought me in to
make something i uh i cook pasta every
now and then this is gonna go either
wonderfully well or uh disastrously
terrible i've just been told that i am
making the two and a half foot anaconda
burrito that was featured on buzzfeed's
worth it this recipe was developed by
edwin and his lovely family at taqueria
yareles the man is carrying giant
tortillas are those regular-sized
tortillas i've actually never made rice
before oh that's a lot of meat ground
beef i'm assuming chopped lettuce pico
de gallo on top and then this green
sauce beans more beans oh he has a good
technique he's like roland
takes two people to carry it that's big
it takes up the entire table because of
the char on it it does look like the
patterns of an anaconda okay a burrito
seems simple enough but a never made a
burrito b never made rice luckily i do
have the wonderful rie to help me here
let's just talk very simply how do i
make rice we made rice together isn't it
what do we make rice usually sticky rice
is cooked in a bamboo steamer but if you
don't have one you can use a regular
steel steamer we did it
but we steamed it we steamed it yes yes
and then what do you think the sauce is
though that's that she's putting in it
because it's it's coloring it and
flavoring say it's tomato ground beef
probably just season it right yeah
you're gonna season with bunch of spice
baked tortilla there's five pico de
gallo i have really good pico de gallo
recipe oh fantastic pinto beans lettuce
salsa verde cheese swiss
cheese the final step is kind of the
tricky one and they put it on a flat top
we take one flat top here like a small
one griddle one here another one here
would that work yeah yeah right i think
thank you so much for you yeah i guess
now i'm gonna go get my ingredients and
then try to put this bad boy together
right now i'm about to start working on
the spanish rice portion of the recipe
as found on allrecipes.com by i love to
cook this person's recipes for five
servings but we're gonna basically items
that by five i've done the math i think
so first i'm just gonna chop up some
onions i took a kitchen safety class
before i was allowed to to do this show
all right so they said to hold it like
this i was holding it like this before
when i was cooking and i'm shaking his
head because you're not supposed to do
that
onions have rings much like a tree and
each ring actually signifies how old the
onion is as well
that's life look at that
grab this and you're just going to put
it in one of these things just to set
aside for later because we're going to
use onions throughout this recipe right
i'm just going to heat some oil in a
large heavy
thing normally you cook rice and water
this one uses chicken broth why i don't
know so it's heating up and sometimes
when you have a moment like this what i
like to do is i can really take the time
to really get into my head a lot and i
stress this is a perfect opportunity to
dip into the stress stash so i don't
know if any of you have done this but i
like to take a nice little chocolate bar
and dip it in some peanut butter it
makes me feel better that's good i took
my break and now the thing's ready to go
beautiful we're going to do a bunch of
oil chopped onion 10 tablespoons oh
that's what we want to hear you want to
hear that sizzle in total i'm putting in
seven cups of rice
10 cups of chicken broth um
five cups of the chunky salsa and then
we let the rice cook down and then we'll
get started on our meat
so we got ourselves four pounds total of
ground beef we're gonna season the meat
first now of course you can use taco
seasoning or anything like that but
we're gonna try and do it the old school
way
oh here we go great oh that's a funny
looking thing
it's quite something this one is the
cayenne a little bit of paprika this is
the cumin pepper or old friend salt now
that it's all there i'm gonna put gloves
on even though i'm not the most
experienced chef or cook i do love
cooking shows travel show
is there something fun about cooking it
may not seem that way but i find it very
calming we're gonna mix oh that's fun ah
wow i gotta do this more often there's
something very calming about just
rolling meat in your hands the rice is
ready it looks like it's getting there i
can try it
it's a little raw when we're out looking
for ingredients i was also keeping my
eye out for an electric griddle and we
actually bought two of them this is the
closest we can do in recreation so but
for now we're going to use this to grill
up the beef get a little bit of oil the
oil's different flavor oh look at that
brown that's exciting to me i won't lie
what i saw in the video is that the meat
beef really just crumbles and so i don't
want it to stick together like a burger
patty i want it to crumble oh that's my
rice there's a significant difference
now
i think it's definitely edible but i
could see how it's all burnt down there
at the bottom we don't want that though
yeah yeah i'm going to give this a
thorough mix to really get the rice
everywhere it needs to come in together
nicely smells great i'm going to start
flipping it now i lost some oh well you
know what this is the purple one i get
to try
a little peppery but it's good making a
mess we're making a mess that's cooking
guys that's cooking and there we have it
beautiful dish what i saw in the video
is that their meat is a little finer
than this it's more crumbly i'm going to
break it up a little bit more with my
hand it's burning my hands yup i don't
think i need to do any more
refried beans this is very new for me
never worked with refried beans ah
juices didn't know that
that's a thing oh
oh
i didn't like that okay
oh here we come there she goes
ah interesting it's quite thick it's not
very wet
it looks a lot smoother consistency it
looks almost wetter how to make refried
beans creamy perfect one right here from
an affair to the heart how to make
canned refried beans tastes like a
restaurant they say adding sour cream is
is the trick we got here creme de
mexicana it's a more authentic mexican
sour cream as a backup i also have just
classic sour cream all right let's put
some sour cream in this and then we'll
see how that works oh i feel like that
already works it feels smoother already
look we all learned something new
together here is that cool i'm gonna
give a little taste
that tastes great i'm gonna add a little
secret ingredient i'm doing a little
nugget of chocolate i'm gonna see if it
adds a little bit of flavor huh and the
thing is we won't tell rie and when she
tastes it
i'm gonna see if she notices
now we're just gonna work on the pico de
gallo using rie's recipe so i'd like
riyad to be here with me for that here's
riya
thank you so much for being here would
you like a chocolate
oh thank you i've been nibbling on these
all day is this a ingredient this is for
my stress
i bought all your ingredients okay i
times it by five mm-hmm look at my
onions what do you think should be a
little smaller
why don't you show me how yeah let's cut
tomato okay okay yeah just like slice
okay i think you just want to go like
dice just dice okay you're doing great
oh thank you you're very sweet do you
have any fun facts about tomatoes
tomatoes feature a lot in italian
cuisine
it's a fact
it's just a [ __ ] great we have extra
tomatoes in case we want to make
gazpacho just shouting a bunch of tomato
base dish yeah okay so i recommend you
to wear gloves when we talk
how to paint okay all right so how are
you cutting these yourself i just cut it
in a half and half because you cut the
end off then you cut in half yeah it's
an honor to cook next to you really
thank you
mine is not quite as nice it's okay
so i'm gonna make it a little bit
smaller you feel free to redo whatever
you need to okay garlic your recipe says
one clove so times five right yeah i can
take my gloves off
ah look at that that was cool this pico
de gallo is gonna be delightful i think
this very well may be the best pico de
gallo that's come out of this best
burrito can you sprinkle something oh
yeah cumin kind of gives a nice flavor
tell me when i think that's good i had a
moment of panic right now when i thought
this might be brown sugar
because i love the brown sugar it's okay
you can stop it
and i just keep going salt now yeah
let's taste it
more salt
oh great
[Music]
more
it's anaconda burrito it has to have a
bite
yep how does it cake i think it's good
it's good it's very hot yeah pico de
gallo is done thank you so much for your
help with this rian look at this look at
that i'm excited about how big it is
it's cool yeah
this is the exciting part early on as
part of my game plan i said i wanted a
train of griddles found these long ones
and so here is that train choo choo so
there is a little uh
design flaw in my plan so there'll be a
little part here that won't get so quite
so grilled but now it's time to uh get
these babies together we got tortillas
these were the biggest we could find
these do seem a little smaller than the
ones he had so this was what he did of
it he would go boom and then he would
put it on top of the other one and then
he would go double it up boom wow so i'm
gonna start layering these already and
then we got this bad boy toasting up
over here put this one on there
oh my oh my look at that just to reheat
i'm not gonna go too crazy we're gonna
go a nice 200 degrees fahrenheit all
right this is done boom does it smell
like decorative relish adam you were
there
yeah
well pretend the first step we got to do
beans i'm gonna just dollop it and then
i'm gonna spread them afterwards this is
starting to look good the rice we're
gonna go into dollops and then i'll
spread it out now we do the same thing
we're gonna just spread all this rice
out huh we could use a little bit more i
think are you at all worried about
overfilling it i'm actually worried
about overfilling this section the end
here actually use a little bit more
that's a little empty over there so i'm
just going to put a little bit more the
refried beans and the rice then the next
is the beef oh that looks great
smells great too it could be i'm just
going to be a little bit more generous
this it looks pretty even right now it
was and there's a little a little dried
little bearing over there making a big
mess
it's gonna be fun to clean all right i
think the meat's done i put a little nub
in here that's uh vegetarian friendly
okay so then the lettuce goes on next
and the pico de gallo might be the most
exciting part because it's fresh
homemade pico de gallo what a joy in
life if you're able to have fresh sauces
made from beautiful on the vine tomatoes
picked out by myself adam bianchi and
don't you worry the vegetarian section
has been loaded with this pico de gallo
so we're going with the crema first
and then last but not least we go with
the salsa verde it looks like a burrito
to me that's all that matters we got a
little cheese this is not swiss cheese
you don't want to use swiss cheese in
your burritos and then of course
vegetarian section get a nice little
handful there this is the daunting part
now i need to watch how he rolls it and
then i gotta pop it on this bad boy
[Music]
folds this end first like this
and then he pull and move over down this
side let me just
[Music]
so he folds that honking oh these are
definitely overstuffed squish them in
[Music]
what do i do adam remember 20 minutes
ago and i was like are you at all
worried about overfilling this and then
added even more rice the end here
actually cues a little bit more that's a
little empty over there i'll make it
work we're gonna just take out a little
bit out of each section i'm gonna keep
this one i'm gonna make a nice little
burrito here for myself a little treat i
deserve
it looks terrible but it tastes great
that's my grill i'm going to say this
for later it's a real technique because
he was like he was like scratching it
that's what he was like scrinching and i
think then he just goes this is the
sense that just kind of just goes with
an extra
roll on each
how does he do this oh look it's coming
together it's two and a half feet i
think of course there's still one more
portion we have to do we have to toast
this bad boy i'm trying to make sure
it's as tight as possible so that way
nothing leaks actually i would
appreciate some help okay so what we're
gonna do is we're going to lift
how you doing
nice it's definitely something you need
to tag to you work on with someone on
this if you're doing this at home so
definitely invite a friend over maybe
your mom and you have to work on this
fun little christmas activity you know
all right before you work it out let's
flip this over how does he do this okay
cover that up cover that up
it's okay it's coming together so now
we're gonna find a way to get this thing
once it's toasted over here
go on three no no wait that's gonna oh
thank god someone's here what happened
so many things went wrong looks like i
missed the good part
you really did so you haven't eaten this
yet
oh i thought you guys were like nibbling
on so we just go in like kind of like
this
sure oh no
oh
my god if we're creative we can even
find a way to flip it over
yeah look at that
the crazy thing is that my mouth is
watering yeah i like steamies looking
good it smells it smells fine what are
your thoughts it looks like a literal
train yeah yeah you know if i had to
rate this on a scale of one to ten i
give us a nice 1.5 i just think it's
very impressive that they're able to not
only make this on a daily basis but they
make so many a day so it's a time-honed
craft what a day i'll remember this one
will i take the first bite of this
beauty i think you guys should recreate
the thumbnail
[Music]
never did i think i'd have to relive
that
mine was all rice mine was all beans
it's tasty it looked like garbage but
that's what we like
come on adam this is pretty good this is
uh to edwin and the family at
taquerialis i'm so sorry
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]